قتل اسرائيليون واصيب 14 في تفجيرين
بالقدس الغربيه وعقب العمليه التي تعتبر
الاولى من نوعها منذ اكثر من ست سنوات طلب
اثمار بن خفير احد زعماء تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه المتطرف باجتياح الضفه الغربيه
وكانت سفاره الامريكيه في اسرائيل
التفجيرين اللذين يتزامنان وتعيين واشنطن
مبعوثا خاصا للشؤون الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله وعوده
التفجيرات الى القدس بعد السنوات رغم
التصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر منذ شهور ضد
الفلسطينيين في القدس والضفه الغربيه وعلى
اي نحو يمكن ان تتاثر حاله التصعيد
الراهنه بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
بترتيبات تشكيل حكومه يقودها نتنياهو كثير
المرشح لتولي حقيبه الامن فيها كذلك ما هو
الموقف الامريكي من هذا التصعيد في ضوء
تزامنه وتعيين اداره ايضا ممثلا خاصا
لشؤون الفلسطينيه ودعوه اليمين
الاسرائيليين وتطرف لاجتياح الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
قتيل اسرائيلي واربعه عشر جريحا وصفت
اصابات ثلاثه منهم بالحرجه في تفجيرين
داخل محطتين متقاربتين للحافلات في القدس
الغربيه العمليه التي تعتبر الاولى منذ
ابريل نيسان عام 2016
مع كبار قاده الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
واكد مكتب لبيد انه سيطلعوا رئيس الحكومه
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو على صوره الوضع
الامني اثره تفجيرين كما ذكر بيان للجيش
الاسرائيلي ان رئيس اركانه
قرر اختصار زيارته الى الولايات المتحده
والعوده الى تل ابيب اسره الاربعاء
اتمر بن الخطير احد زعماء التحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرف والمرشح الاقوى
لتولي حقيبه الامن الداخلي في حكومه
نتنياهو الجديده طالب لدى وصوله موقع احد
التفجيرين باجتياح الضفه الغربيه
لتمشيط والتفتيشي منازل الفلسطينيين فيها
جاء تفجير يوم الاربعاء في القدس الغربيه
بعد الشهور من حملات قمع ودهما وتفتيش
تشلها اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين في القدس
والضفه الغربيه كان اخر ضحاياها الفتى
الفلسطيني احمد شحاده البالغ من العمر 16
عاما والذي شيع جثمانه في نابلس غازات
استشهاده على ايدي قوات الاحتلال شرقيه
المدينه اثر اصابته برصاصه اخترقت قلبه في
عمليه دهم اسرائيليه او وقعت ايضا خمسه
مصابين وصفت جراحه بعضهم بالحرجه
[موسيقى]
والي مناقشته هذا الموضوع معنا من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن حيث
الدكتور سليم بريك محاضره في العلوم
السياسيه والمختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن يوجد
الامريكي في مفاوضات السلام بالشرق الاوسط
سابقا اهلا بكم جميعا الى ما وراء الخبر
وابدا معك استاذ سليم بريك بعد انقطاع ست
سنوات عادت التفجيرات الى القدس ليس تفجير
بل تفجيرين
بعد يعني عمليات دهم وقمع ومحاولات عديده
من جانب الاسرائيليين لايقاف هذا النوع من
الهجمات
كيف ينظر اسرائيل
وعدد الشرح
كبير نسبيا ولكن طبعا هناك عده اسئله
مازلنا لا نعرف السبب اولا الاسباب
المبدئيه واضحه هذه الحكومه حتى الحكومه
الحاليه التي لم تنهي ولايتها بعد لاحقت
الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل بشكل شرس نحن راينا
هذا الامر في همم
في الجنين حتى الامر في نابلس اكثر من مره
في القدس المحتله الشيخ جراح في عده اماكن
اولا وثانيا لم هناك اي بادره امل امام
الشعب الفلسطيني الى اين ممكن ان ان نتقدم
لا يوجد افق سياسي هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
الثانيه هذا التفجير على المستوى همم
تحليلي مثلا نحن نرى بانهسق في منطقتين
مختلفتين تم استعمال على ما يبدو همم همم
قنبله زمنيه هناك مستوى عالي من التخطيط
همم من ناحيه ثانيه نحن نرى بانها السلطه
اسرائيل لم تستطع في وسطه اجهزه
الاستخبارات ان تمنع هذا
تفجير ولذلك هناك عده اسئله وايه واضح
اننا ذاهبين الى تصعيد في المناطق
الفلسطينيه هذا اضافه الى الحدث الخط
ير اختطاف بجريح من حادث الطرق همم وقتل
وخطفه هذا عمل عن غير مسبوق ولا يليق
عن عمليه قياده وطنيه
محاربا للاحتلال ولكن هذا سي- سيزيت من
حده همم الغضب الاسرائيلي ورده الفعل
الاسرائيليه في منطقه جنين اذا لم يتم همم
اعاده جثمان همم جثمان هذا الفتى باسرع
نقطه
في تنسيق يعني بين التفجيرين وهذا ما
اسالك عنه دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي اذا اردت
ان يعني فقط ان ارد ما قاله وزير الامن
الداخلي الاسرائيلي يقول انه هجوم القدس
مركب ومعقد ويبدو انه نتيجه بني تحتيه
منظمه يعني يشارك انه يعني يلمح لانه ليس
عمل فردي وانما جهه منظمه تقف ورائه
هذه
التصريحات من وجهه نظرك يعني ماذا تقرا
فيها انت
الذي يقرا بكل وضوح اولا في تناقض في
الدعاءات الاسرائيليه واكثر الادعاءات
تقول انه ما زال هذا عمل فردي هيك بيحكوا
لكن المساله الاهم ماذا يعني الذي جرى
الذي جرى يعني ان هناك فشل اسرائيلي فشل
في قمع المقاومه الفلسطينيه فشل في
استخدام اسلوب القمع والتنكيل والقتل في
وقف النضال الوطني الفلسطيني هذا هو
الاستنتاج الرئيسي والاهم والامر الثاني
انه فعلا الضفه الغربيه والاراضي المحتله
كما قلنا مرارا وتكرارا تشهد حاله انتفاضه
شعبيه جديده منذ عام 2015
وتتكرر ملامحها على شكل موجات متتاليه
وباشكال مقاومه مختلفه ومتعدده
وماذا وهذا هو طبعا النتيجه الطبيعيه
للسياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والعنصريه الاجراميه التي وصلت الى حد
استقدام حزب في شيء الى الحكم في اسرائيل
الحزب فيها شيء يقول زعيم وبينج فير انه
يريد ان يطهر عرقيا الكره الفلسطينيه يريد
ان يكرر نكبه ال 48 هذه التصريحات
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي طبعا الشعب
الفلسطيني رد الفعل لديه هو المقاومه
والكفاح منذ بدايه هذا العام 200 شهيد
وشهيد سقطوا حتى الان استشهدوا ومنهم 46
طفل اخرهم طفل في نابلس اذا نحن نتحدث عن
اجرام اسرائيلي متواصل لا يتوقف وعلى فكره
في موضوع الجثمين ايضا نحن لا نريد لاي
شخص ان يحتجز جسمها ولكن دعيني اذكر رقما
اسرائيل تحتج 373 جثمان فلسطيني منهم 12
طفل صور 12 طفل محتجزه ثمينهم ومنهم تسع
اسره استشهدوا في السجون ويبقوهم في الاسر
ومنهم الثنتين من النساء هاي الحكومه
اجراميه عنصريه تمارس الفاشيه باوضح صورها
وبالتالي طبعا رد الفعل الفلسطيني انه
واسرائيل تفشل في وقف المقاومه وكل هذا
روتشيلد كوتستين لا تعلق عليه الولايات
المتحده السفاره الامريكيه في تل ابيب
اختارت ان تدين التفجيرين الاخرين ولكن لم
تعلق ابدا على ما حصل خلال الاشهر الماضيه
الفلسطينيه
هل يتوقع ان يقبل الفلسطينيون هذه
الازدواجيه من واشنطن وهي التي تقدم نفسها
راعيا للحل
المشكله بالتاكيد تعود الى عقود كثيره من
الوراء
واننا لا نعرف بالضبط اي اتجاه ستصير عليه
الامور حاليا هل ستكون تصعيد واعتقد ان
التاريخ
في مؤخرا هو ربطا نفسه
بالجمهوريه
جمهوريه من اليهود في الولايات المتحده
بتقديم بعض الملاحظات اعتقد الناس انها
خارج المالوف واعت اداره سبايدر مان في
الوقت وانا متاكد ان اداره سوف
تعترضوا على اي اجراء تقوم به حكومه
نتنياهو في المستقبل
للتواصل مع
او الهجوم عليه المجموعات في الضفه
الغربيه هذا ليس امرا مطروحا واعتق من
اسرائيل سترتكب خطا
لانها بدات تقوم بالكثير اتصالات تحسين
العلاقات
اسرائيل بالمهاجمتها على الفلسطيني بهذا
الشكل هل هذا معاي المستوى اترك الجواب
على ذلك لاخرين وانا افهم لماذا ان
الفلسطينيين يودنا ان امريكا تقوم بشيء
اكثر ولكن هناك بعض خلف الكواليس اذا
اعتقد ان هناك الامور
يعني الى اي حد هذه الجهود ستبذل وسيقبل
بها الفلسطينيون هذا امر ربما سنتابعه
ولكن دكتور سليم بريك عندما يقول رجل مثل
اثمار من الكفير اننا يجب ان نجاح الضفه
الغربيه ان نفتش البيوت الفلسطينيه
كل هذا ليس هو ليس رجل عادي هو رجل يتوقع
ان يتقلد حقيبه الامن الداخلي في الحكومه
المقبله فهذا نوع من التصريح الى اي حد
يمثل
الحكومه المقبله وهل هو مقبول في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
اولا طبعا مقبول في داخل اسرائيل وقد حصل
على اكثر من ثمانيه اعطاك كنيسه ال ال
الحزب الصينيه الدينيه مركب من قسمين اسمه
مدرج بالمناسبه هو اشد عنصريه وخطوره من
بينغوير وهو صدحت الماضي انه يرفض ان تكون
زوجته مع في المستشفى
عربيه يعني هذه تصريحات من المانيا
انه حتى في النقود هناك عناصر التي تشبه
بنت كبيره يعني عندما يقول اسرائيل سبيل
المثال الذي كان وزير هام في اسرائيل
انه يجب على العرب في الداخل ان يت النكبه
فهذا التهديد مباشر على همم على المواطنين
العرب والنجاح الذي حضر به بن كدير هو
عمليا نتيجه لارين الامر الاول بنظره هو
فعلا شعور بالخوف بالداخل الاسرائيلي لان
داخل الاسرائيلي يرى بانه لا يستطيع ان
يتخلص من القضيه الفلسطينيه كل من اعتقد
بانه ممكن ان تختفي القضيه الفلسطينيه
وايه ربما
[موسيقى]
اكتشف ان هذا الامر لا يمكن ان يحدث ان
يجب ان يكون هناك حل ولذلك هناك خوف فعلا
لان الشعب الاسرائيلي لا يريد الحل
بالنسبه لما همم سالت مثلا في السابق
بالنسبه همم
الضيف السابق بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
انا اعتقد
بانه قسم
من المشير ده بروسيس النظ ذا بيس يعني نحن
اا العمليه السلام وعمليه السلام لا دائما
نتذكر مثلا سياره بايدا
خ هو صرح بشكل واضح في داخل اسرائيل بان
حال الدوله التاين هو المطروح ولكن ليس في
الف
تره يعني هذا انه ليس منزل حقيقه بحل
الدوله وهذا زعيم الحزب الديمقراطي فاذا
هو اعطى دفعه قويه
بان همم الطريق مفتوحه القضيه الثانيه انه
اسرائيل ترجمات
همم اشاره خضراء لان تقوم في الضفه
الغربيه بما تريد ان نتنياه صرحت في
قبل فتره قصيره بان ااه حل السلام لا يمر
عن طريق رام الله نهائيا اي انه السلام
يجب انما عن طريق دول الخليج السعوديه او
يتحدث عن السعوديه
وليس عن طريق رام الله فاذا هو لا يريد
السلام مع
جيراء من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه الولايات
المتحده لا تحرك ساكن حقيقي من اجل التفوق
في العمليه
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي ما هي خيارات
الفلسطينيين
في ظلمه تقوم باسرائيل وفي ظل الصمت
الدولي بالمناسبه احد اهم اسباب الانعطاء
في العنصر الشامل في اسرائيل مش بس على
مستوى الاحزاب والحكومه كل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي رايح على العنصريه والفاشيه
هذا احد اهم اسباب صمت المجتمع الدولي على
الجرائم الاسرائيليه
وصمته وسماحه لاسرائيل بان تكون فوق
القانون الدولي وفوق المحاسبه وطبعا يلام
في ذلك اولا همم الحكم القائم في الولايات
المتحده وكذلك هي الدول الغربيه بشكل عام
هذا الصمت والسكوت وايضا يشارك في هذا
الصمت كل من يطبع مع اسرائيل في ظل
الاستمرار احتلالها ما هو البديل امام
الفلسطينيين في ظل هذه الحكومه والحكومه
القادمه وهذا الانعطاف اليمين العنصري لا
يوجد سواحل واحد توحيد الصف الفلسطيني
بسرعه على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم
اسرائيل تقول كل يوم انها لا تفهم الا لغه
القوه وبدون تغيير ميزان القوه لن غير شيء
انظري ماذا يقول الامريكان يريد تهدئه
تهدئه ونحن تحت الاحتلال تهدئه ونحن تحت
القمع تهدئه وهم يقتلون بنا تهدئه ونحن
نعاني من نظام افرتايد وتمييز عنصري لماذا
يعني لماذا يريد فقط الهدوء الاسرائيليين
والامل الاسرائيليين ولا يهمهم ما يجري
الفلسطينيين بالتالي لا حل سوى توحيد
الفلسطينيين على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم
وايضا لابد الان من فضح وتعريه حكام
اسرائيل خاصه بعد وجود حزب فاشل في هذه
الحكومه الان هناك فرصه ذهبيه للمطالبه
بالمقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على اسرائيل ورد
الفعل الشعبي العربي الرائع الذي رايناه
في مونديال قطر وفي في الشارع القطري وهذا
الرد يظهر بكل وضوح ان الشعوب العربيه
كلها مع الشعب الفلسطيني ولا تقبل
بالتطبيع وتريد ان تعزل اسرائيل على
الجرائم التي تقوم بها
السف الامريكيه في تل ابيب من ادانا
للتفجيرين في القدس وقالت انها تراقب
الوضع عن كثب طبعا فقط تجدر الاشاره الى
ما نقله موقع اكسيوس الامريكيه عن مسؤول
رفيع في الخارجيه الامريكيه ان انا اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغت الكونجرس تعيين
هادي عمر ممثلا خاصا لشؤون الفلسطينيه كما
نقل الموقع عن مصدر فلسطيني قوله ان
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس ابدى تحفظات
بشان المنصب الجديد في اول الامر لكنه بعد
ذلك تقبل الامر همم في الاسابيع الاخيره
ان السلطه الفلسطينيه همم قالت انها تتفق
مع القرار وستعمل مع عمرو وقابلت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المنتهيه والولايتها بهذه الخطوه كما
ابلغت بها مسبقا رئيس الوزراء المكلف
بنيامين نتنياهو ومستشاريه كذلك
ساندوتشد
هذا التعيين اريد ان افهم يعني حيثياته
هذه عمر ممثلا خاصه لشؤون الفلسطينيين في
هذا الوقت ما الذي يسعى اليه
من خلال هذا التعيين برايك
بان هناك
ابتعاد او
المنطقه
التي لم
اطلاقا بتوصل للتواصل باي نوع من انواع
السلام بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيه وفلسطينيه
السياسه
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في المجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي قبل ان يصبح رئيسا نائب رئيس
لمده ثمان سنوات حيث كان يحمل الملف
العلاقات الدوليه
اذا هذا رجل
القوه
الضعف هذه
قوتهم وقد اظهر ذلك عندما جمع بالتحالف
لواجه بوتين هذا نعرف ان هذا يعرف يحقق
الامور وان حكمه همم بتعيين هذا الشخص
ممثلا المصالح الفلسطينيه هو امرا هو في
رايه يبعث له اشاره
ويقصد ذلك بانه لا يتم تحدي الجاده فيما
يتعلق بالسير على تطبيق حل للدولتين طبعا
الدفع بهذا الموضوع الى الوراء ولكن
الرئيس
لديه نظره طويله لانه للتاكد الفلسطيني
من خلال تعيين هذه عام ربما هذه خطوه كما
يقول رجل دكتور مصطفى ضروري
الرئيس ابو مازن تحفظ ثم تقبل الامر انت
برايك ما قراءتك لهذا التحفظ للموقف هذا
من جانب الرئيس وما كيف ترى امكانيه فعلا
ان يقدم هذه عمرو شيء جديد
التحفظ الفلسطيني اعتقد انه مردود انه
سببه انه هذه الخطوه اللي قام بها الرئيس
الامريكي محاوله للهروب من الالتزامات
الامريكيه الالتزام الامريكي الاول الذي
تعهد به بايدن ولم ينفضه هو فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس لم يفعل ذلك الالتزام
الثاني فتح مكتب منظمه التحرير في واشنطن
لم يتم ذلك الالتزام الثالث ان يكون هناك
ضغط من اجل البدء بعمليه السياسيه لم يحدث
شيء وبالتالي تعين مبعوث يعني شو شو له
قيمه طبعا الاجانب الفلسطيني وفي الاخر
سيلتقي معه ويتحدث معه ولكن هل هذا يعني
تغيير حقيقي في الموقف الامريكي لا هل هذا
يعني ان هناك ضغط امريكي على اسرائيل نحن
لا نرى ضغطا امريكيا على اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده لو ارادت تستطيع ان
توقف الاستيطان خلال اربع ساعات اذا قالت
لاسرائيل سنوقف عنكم كل المساعدات ان لم
توقفوا الاستيطان مثلا
ولكن طبعا الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه ايضا
في حاله حرج لانه مش بس الاداره الامريكيه
دول كثيره وحكومات كثيره تدعم اسرائيل في
حاله حرج شديد لانه الفضيحه اصبحت كامله
والعود رقيقات الاسرائيليه عنصريه
مؤشر او امل لدور امريكي حقيقي في هذه
المرحله القادمه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا وفي القضيه الروسيه وفي الصين
واشاره اسيا هي ليست مشغوله في الشرق
الاوسط عمليا وكل ما تريده في القضيه
الفلسطينيه هي محاوله
الصراع حسب وجهه نظر الامريكان وهم غير
معليين في الدخول عمليا في هذا الموضوع
انه رساله الامريكان لاكثر من مناسبه ان
هذا وجع راس كبير وانا لا اعتقد انهم
يبدون اهتمام كبير بما يعاني في الشعب
الفلسطيني في المناطق المحتله سواء كان في
الضفه الغربيه شرقي القدس او حتى في غزه
اشكرك دكتور سليم بريكه المحضر في العلوم
السياسيه مختصر في الشؤون الاسرائيليه من
حيفا شكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه من رام
الله
زياده
السلام في الشرق الاوسط سابقا وشكرا لكم
طبعا مشاهدينا الى ان التقدم
[موسيقى]